mais 1200 euros monsieur ils n'ont pas
augmenté depuis 10 ans
alors moi je me retrouve avec une
retraite pareil que quelqu'un qui a
jamais bossé quoi parce que moi j'ai des
gens autour de moi dans mon village ils
n'ont jamais travaillé ils ont 900 euros
par mois tu habites un petit village
profond de la France où il y a rien il y
a pas on est obligé de prendre la
voiture pour n'importe quoi donc moi si
vous voulez c'est très dur pour nous je
ne peux pas acheter de poisson je ne
peux pas acheter tout le temps de la
viande de temps en temps j'emmène les
petits au McDo manger le Happy me la
4,95 et c'est tout la sortie vous
comprenez et j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
voilà alors moi il y a quand même
quelque chose que je vais vous poser je
pense que tout le monde serait d'accord
et Cyril aussi comment se fait-il que
les sénateurs les députés et tous ces
gens là ils aient des retraites
spéciales il parle